Nik there are no tutorials in SIA
thieves they are not so welcome to the
sea of thieves which is an actual place
and welcome to the game so the first
time you fire up the game it's obviously
not gonna tell you what to do as this is
kind of a maker or an adventure game you
could say so
we've spawned in to the tavern at one of
the various outposts so it's important
to note that there are many many
outposts throughout the sea of Thieves
and so wow that was beautiful I love
that so welcome to one of the many
outposts and here is basically where
you're going to start every time you
fire up the game whether it's your first
time your second time or your hundredth
time so basically what we're looking at
here are all different kind of places
where you can earn money spend your
money and kind of this is where your
journey is going to begin
and your voyages are going to end so
let's let's begin by going over the
three factions that are available right
now gonna start with him so the first
faction is the gold hoarders this is
Humphrey the hoarder so basically the
gold hoarders they are they are
searching for gold in the form of chests
and artifacts so those are the two
things you can bring back to him so when
you come here if you choose to begin
your journey as a gold hoarder you'll
gain quests that'll be x marks the spot
and riddle quests so that's the first
faction the next faction we're going to
is let's head over towards the docks and
then yes perfect
so the second faction that we're headed
towards it's called the merchants
alliance so the merchant of lights is
looking to kind of support and control
the trade of all along see thieves and
so these interesting merchants will ask
you to go on kind of these these fetch
quests to find specific animals whether
it's a chicken pigs or snakes and you'll
have to go out there catch them in cages
and crates and baskets and bring them
back to the merchants alliance the
caveat is is that they'll give you a
time limit so you'll need to meet your
your fulfilment you'll need to fulfill
your order on time
also two of very specific outposts it's
also important to note that right when
you load into sea of thieves it's
usually a good idea to pick up a couple
of these quests because that is how you
earn reputation that's how you get more
gold and it also gives your your your
crew something to do as you play right
right as we're walking by these are all
different trading posts and places where
you can spend your gold but let's head
in and this is the tavern and then we'll
head to the final the final trade
company so I think the final trade
company it's typically below a building
I think it's behind you let's see so I
think it's behind you behind the gold
hoarders behind the gold so the final
the final trade companies as we walk
over there is called the order of souls
and so the order there they are and so
the order of souls are these mysterious
group of NPCs that are attempting to
kind of control the magic of these
skeleton lords and pirates and so
they'll give you bounty quests and
bounty voyages and those bounties will
have you go out and try to fight an
entire dead captains crew and then
defeat the captain in order to collect
their skull if you can successfully
bring their skull back to let's say an
outpost with with at the order of souls
you'll be granted money and infection
reputation so why don't we go ahead and
go out on one of these order of souls
questions we haven't seen much too much
about this particular faction yeah the
other two were in both beta or and in
some of the babes right some of the
betas some of the scale tests some of
the alphas so we've we've seen a lot of
the gold orders seen a good amount of
the The Merchant Alliance but we haven't
seen much of the order of souls all
right so once you've selected a quest
whether it's one of the three factions
you'll want to come to your ship and
propose the voyage you want to go on
Europe so you're looking at some of
Jake's voyages so he's proposed
obviously the order of souls quest and
he's gonna vote for that voyage in order
to initiate it when you initiate a
voyage it'll let you know it'll list the
the members of your your crews there you
Jake is is gonna go on this voyage and
he's received one-one bounty for two
captain's that have been last seen on
Cannon Cove so the next thing you want
to do is you want to go down to your map
and take a look at where is canon code
now you're saying they're usually pretty
close to the island up yep see they're
pretty close the island you pick them up
and as we can see it's just just right
to the south got to do a 180 and head
south so now we'll talk about a little
bit about operating your ship so the
most important thing to do when you
begin is lift the anchor with the sails
up this allows you to pivot and turn
your ship without bumping into things
and causing unnecessary damage to your
ship I think it's one of the most
important pro tips that like new players
should know even though Jake is gonna
rub against this dock here a little bit
it won't cause damage simply because the
sales are up
I don't even rub against it look at that
oh yeah perfect so doing a little 180
tearing himself towards Cannon Cove oh I
think I did just rub up against it but
we're good alright so we are just about
going in the direction we want I believe
that when the wind is at our backs -
alrighty Oh too much little too much Oh
perfect
so Jake as a single sailor he is sailing
on a single sailed sloop and so single
sails loops have everything that a
single sailor would need that includes
the map here as he looks over the side
which means he doesn't have to go
downstairs
it is the sail where he can raise and
lower it right here and then if he needs
to adjust the sails whether it's right
or left in order to catch the wind he
can do that as well now it's important
to note that galleons are obviously
gonna be different there are four of you
or three and so there's more people so
the map will be located in the lower
deck the anchor will be located at the
front of the boat and then obviously
there'll be four cannons on each side
opposed to one there are three sails
opposed to one so it's obviously more
difficult to man
would you like that and would you look
at that
so that might look like something pretty
but Jake's can tell you why it's not yes
so that those are raids essentially and
that's how you get lots of Lube
basically you go to an island fight off
hordes of skeletons defeat of captain
and you get access to a volt which has a
ton of loot unfortunately since we are a
one ship or a one-man crew right now it
would not be wise of us to stroll in
there definitely not wise and so that's
why if you're a single sailor your best
bet is to go on order of souls quest
because that'll give you a smaller more
manageable spirit that's the same or if
you can get in touch with some of the
other pirates around and maybe they're
doing it maybe you can lend a hand that
works too however you have to be careful
because you're not gonna share that loot
with them right I mean you can't share
the cam but by like allistic it yeah
they might put a bullet in your head
so they can claim all the loot for
themselves and that's that's the thing
you need to remember about this game see
if these is a shared world and so
obviously we're going on a quest right
now that is that is PvE focused but
because there are many many other
sailors and other pirates on the seas
here you can also kind of fall into that
PvP mode at a moment's notice and so
that's kind of the beauty of this game
and why it's it's kind of a
choose-your-own-adventure and also why
it's a little bit difficult when you
first get started so hoping that what
we're showing you guys today will help
you kind of get settled and get on your
first journey and start to learn the
game's basics so here we are we've made
it to Cannon Cove let's see if I can see
I can drop this anchor and land with us
let's see I'll be very impressive you
can get near this dock
maybe turns you can fire someone short
I'd say that's but just about perfect so
there are two two emergent things we've
seen so far you can see that storm out
to the left which is kind of encroaching
so you might want to get through this
before the stern storm arrives and
obviously the skull raid is also an
emergent gameplay there's a lot of
interesting things that happened
aside from quests but we're just gonna
go over the basics so we are looking for
two captains well who are we looking for
we're looking for kept canceled orcs are
so cold and nightmare and nightmare
what's that say I think it's anger name
your anger yeah I think all right so
let's quickly stock up on some resources
that you can find in barrels oh and we
have begun the order of souls so you'll
often run into skeletons throughout your
journeys throughout your quests and
basically they will have you know they
won't be wearing any cosmetic items
these skeletons however are wearing blue
bandanas and so these blue bandanas
these blue eye patches signify that they
are part of these these skeleton crews
that you're searching for
so as you defeat them they will come in
waves hope you might want to heal a
little bit because he has a gun all
right we're healing up healing up eating
some bananas up shot the poor chicken
that skeleton shot that poor defenseless
chicken Oh more bananas those guys got
storm trooper aim over here alright so
looks like he's the last one of this
particular way
all right shake his defeated the first
wave it looks like them the next wave is
coming it's kind of a bummer that
there's no ammo chests around me right
now because yeah he's got a blunderbuss
so ammo ammo is a bit scarce so you have
to choose to either battle them with
your sword and Cutlass or get out of
there
run or heal oh so you have to choose to
kind of manage your inventory I think
the smart move here for you would either
be to run back to the boat and reload or
just continue to take them one with one
at a time we're gonna do one at a time
just cuz I don't wanna you're doing
pretty well it looks like you just
defeated the entire second wave yep got
two bananas left this guy had a poor
unfortunate end yeah alright so we've
defeated two waves thus far maybe I
believe there's a Mon here Dwight big
coming no but there's some wooden planks
you see ancient homes watch out though
don't get yourself stuck here oh yeah
Jerry they're rolling in on you looks
like there's three left one is a
blunderbuss alright do you have a
charged attack too if you want to show
them that right here whoa that was
devastating for them that's how you
showcase the charged attack that was
awesome little quad kill there so some
bananas in here too yeah alright grab
those bananas and I believe you're next
right there he is I hope he doesn't have
a gun a gun he has no gun but he so the
captain's will have more health and
they'll be far deadlier oh oh all right
so now we've seen the challenge now good
news is good news is even though the two
captains who kind of ganged up on you
unfairly have defeated you you've come
to the ferry of the Damned so don't be
alarmed
when you come here don't be alarmed well
unless your boat sank then you should be
alarmed to my side since our boat
survived I can respond on my bus right
so I can jump right back in and finish
it's right I want to look at
captain up here he's pretty cool looking
at too so don't be alarmed if you're a
new player and this happens so obviously
it's difficult to play as a single
player other crews may defeat you other
skeleton raids might might defeat you
don't worry you go through the little
portal here and you'll come right back
onto your ship and you can continue the
quest you were on alright so we're back
on the ship so oh wait grab some ammo
grab something and I should have some
already oh you do okay alright so we've
replenished ammo and we're gonna head
back and try to defeat these two
captains who unfairly ganged up on you
alright so we're moving in no ammo keep
an eye out for ammo it really makes a
difference if we can find an ammo crate
somewhere around here already Hyrum
certain islands well of ammo
certainly not oh there they expose those
on both of them let's go boys see if you
can lure them in all right you got it
we're gonna all right so we're
blunderbuss seeing the captain so here I
know we were talking about this a little
bit earlier the captains are obviously
stronger you're faster and one of the
interesting things that they can do that
a lot of the other skeletons cannot is
they can heal themselves so they
themselves can eat bananas yes the
undead can eat banana oh nice it's one
down one down his crew is still
defending him all right I've got no ammo
left oh so let's but I think I can deal
with all right I think it's just the see
if a gun oh he's got a blunderbuss
capitan coming after you I'm gonna get a
I'm gonna get some ammo
alright Jake seemed grab some ammo from
the ship so another thing too so as as
you're going back and forth from the
ship to the island the ship and back and
whatnot keep your eyes peeled always be
looking around whether it's looking for
other ships but also looking for hidden
treasures just because you came to a
specific Island doesn't mean that's the
only thing that's there they are often
hidden treasures hidden trinkets skulls
just lying around that you can take and
although they're not a part of your
specific quest line that you're on you
can still
use them to your advantage and gain
reputation among these factions and so I
guess this is a good time to kind of
mention to the reason why we watch a
shark and assume the reason why you do
these things the reasons why you're
you're going out of these quests going
out of these voyages is because you're
attempting to increase your reputation
among the factories right now a lot of
us believe that the endgame is you're
looking to get your quests to about 50
each and so once each of your faction
levels is at 50 that'll be when some of
the more endgame content beginners oh
boy he's strong yes all right
no plea doesn't heal up he's healing
he's healing all right one more and then
and then take some swings got him not
cool all right so now that now we got to
pick up their skulls right all right so
you've got the first goal and it looks
like a storm is rolling in where did I
kill the other one the other one I
believe should be right to your left
there oh cool
so you can only carry one at a time this
is nice about having multiple feet oh my
chapter two so there another thing about
these quests are as you progress through
your different levels you will gain more
lucrative quest lines and so this
specific quest line has multiple
chapters so you completed chapter one
there's a chapter two there's a final
chapter that could be chapter three for
the purposes of us teaching you I think
we'll just go ahead and bring these two
skulls back and show you how you would
turn them and how you gained that
reputation and you return that back and
you earn the gold so you can purchase
some things so there's one and then
let's go grab the other one real quick
yes
hot tip hot tip if you're on top of
something let's say a rock or your boat
you kind of do one of those lunged
attacks that you saw Jake do that
devastating for kill blow on it will
also thrust you forward through the air
through the water and get you on it's
it's super helpful because you don't
need to line up a cannon you don't need
to worry it I mean obviously if you're
trying to get somewhere really far don't
do it cuz you're still gonna have to
swim a good distance and the cannons
will be there quicker but like from
where I am it makes just as much sense
to do that as it would matter that
cannon I set up
I'm loving the skeleton cloud in the
background as you carry the skull yeah
yeah that's pretty cool alright it's
like you said there is another chapter
however we're gonna return from which we
came and we are going to deliver these
skulls and get some reputation hopefully
some some cash money yep so luckily it's
night time and doesn't look like the
storms hit us so we're gonna look for
the closest outpost so we see sanctuary
is there but an easy way to see outpost
says at night is those islands will be
illuminated so I think when you go on
your top deck you should be able to see
both of those outposts in the area so
there's one that's a little further away
it's the one I'm looking for is north so
I think it's that one and I believe
there's another one if you turn to your
left and there's another one that one
looks pretty close oh what's southwest
oh yeah golden coast golden sands out
that one right there perfect yep you can
mark and d mark the map one important
thing to note though is that so for this
quest I can return to any outpost to
turn it in however with the merchant
exchange or the merchant alliance you
have to go to the one where you took
that quest from or a specific one it'll
note it'll tell you which one you need
to go to right because last night I was
playing and I had you know caged some
chickens as you do and I was like let's
return these quick because I want to try
out this raid so we we went to the
nearest outpost and they're like sorry
we can't accept this this is for a
different Island and I was like are you
kidding me I'm like well we'll just sell
it anyway we got 13 gold apiece yep so
it's a so don't waste your time don't
waste your time by returning the wrong
loot to the wrong outpost what you can
however do is if you're on and I
and you noticed that there's a random
cage sitting around you can grab that
cage go you know check a like grab a
chicken and and put it in the coop if
you do return that without having a
merchant Alliance quests set up you will
gain gold like normal but if you have a
specific list of items you need to earn
those things well affect how much you
earn so we can see the outpost in the
distance there is all lumen ated that's
how you know those are outpost versus
regular islands with loot and again as
you can see as a single sailor
everything that Jake needs is right
there within arm's reach let's see let's
see if we can turn these sails a little
bit looks like yeah ones going right to
left perfect so he's caught the wind
here he's gonna steer himself right into
Shore and so like we said we first began
the video here your journey and your
voyages will start and stop along along
these lines of the outpost so you will
you'll find them you'll find your your
beginnings here and you'll complete them
here as well
it's coming in we are coming into the
outpost alright so when you arrive
you'll want to take a quick look-see and
make sure that no other rival ships are
nearby because it was good
take him and then you're gonna grab your
leet whether that's a chest a chicken in
a coop a pig in a crate a skeleton head
like this a skull and then you're gonna
bring him to the merchant so I believe
the merchants are off to your right
yeah pretty far away didn't pick the
best side to land on but that's okay
good news is golden golden sands outpost
is pretty small I like I put that sky
that beautiful sky beautiful beautiful
that is the one thing that I will say
this game does exceptionally the beauty
is unbelievable
alright so this is the tavern so you
can't return to the tavern but you can
however cross that bridge in return
that's a bonus that is cool so so here's
the breakdown skulls can be returned to
the order of souls which is Jay what
Jake is doing now your chests like
treasure chests and any types of
artifacts you may find there you go 191
gold chests and artifacts you'll find
like gold artifacts those can be
returned to the gold orders so they
collect those two things and then to
complete your things for their merchant
alliance those will be either chickens
snakes or pigs and those you when you
collect them you can sell those and and
also a side note is you can find
gunpowder barrels and you can find
crates of let's say tea bananas sugar
those things can be returned to the
merchant lines so those are how the the
three breakdowns are so Jake's running
back to his ship god I couldn't have
parked that any further away he's gonna
grab the last piece of loot we have as
the Sun rises here what do they say for
pirates
Sun sight at night sailor's delight
sunset and morning sailors take warning
so it could be that a storm was coming I
don't know if that's true in the game or
not who knows I know it's true in real
life but all right there's the next
piece of loot II as I love it we've seen
the full day tonight
- morning and once he delivers that
we'll take a look at how our our faction
reputation has been moving up please
note that during the first week or so
sometimes it takes a little while for
your your faction reputation to load in
sometimes your gold knight might not
load in right away but those things are
obviously the kinks are being worked out
as this is so early and obviously we
hope that this video serves to help you
guys understand what it takes to begin
your journey to pirate legend kind of
understand what's going on in this this
giant world that doesn't really tell you
what to do we can swing by maybe a
merchant after maybe Jay can buy himself
a hat or something don't save him my
money he's saving his money and there
you go you go 274 not bad not bad at all
so once you've done that then you can
obviously go to the different merchants
we can just quickly walk by them and
then we'll conclude things here so here
this is where you can purchase gear so
if you want to get different types of
shovels and buckets and tankards that's
the story you want to go to if you want
to buy new cosmetic kind of skins for
your weapons then you would come here to
the armory via that gold that you've
just earned and you would spend them
here and then the last one obviously is
more cosmetic that's the one with the
boot on top and that's where you can buy
hats peg legs eye patches beards all
kinds of stuff and that would be here
and that's what you're what you're kind
of doing these quests towards to earn
weight that and to become pirate legend
and to become pirate legend but yeah I
think that about wraps us up if you guys
have any more
questions feel free to hit either of us
up on Twitter we've been playing a lot
of it so we should hopefully be able to
help and yeah good luck out there on the
Seas be nice to one another or choose to
be you know pirates and and get scurvy
and sink other ships and whatnot but but
yeah get out there really enjoy the
world explore it create your own
adventures it's it's definitely a very
interesting place to be
you